for several days as I'm sure you heard
the media had been have been hyping up
this white supremacist neo-nazi KKK
rally that was supposed to happen in DC
yesterday Sunday and then Sunday rolls
around and a couple dozen white
supremacist show up along with throngs
of news cameras and hundreds of counter
protesters and the alt-right folks just
they were there for less than two hours
I believe they just kind of walked down
the street then they stood around in a
field for a little bit and and then they
left and that was it there wasn't there
was no violence on that part there
really no theatrics nothing happened
they just walked they stood around
looking a bit overwhelmed and sad and
they left because it started to rain and
so they figured well I guess we might as
well reconvene in the internet comment
section no reason for us to be out here
in the rain and so that's what happened
nothing to notice nothing at all
whatever violence or theatrics occurred
on Sunday it was it was all on the part
of an Tifa which also gathered in
various places including some including
DC and and other places and in some
instances got into altercations with the
media and others they also carried signs
attacking the police
so this counter protest against a couple
of white supremacists turned into a
counter protest against the police and I
guess because I guess if you get there
and you don't have any white
supremacists to yell at then you figure
well we gotta yell at somebody let's
just yell at the police you got to feel
kind of bad for an T but especially at
any ante for folks who came a little bit
late and then they got there and they're
like hi everyone all the white
supremacist law well I guess we'll just
have the shot at the police then I mean
I came here to shout at somebody I'm not
gonna go home without shouting all in
all it was really an incredibly
embarrassing scene for everybody
involved for everybody involved except
for the police who comported themselves
professionally but for everybody else it
was embarrassing
because you've got a few dumb racists
walking down the street holding signs
and they are absolutely surrounded by
media encounter protesters who have all
shown up for the sake of these
completely irrelevant obscure idiots
just imagine if you I mean if you've
seen anything over it you've seen how
it's just a ridiculous a few guys
walking and then Hertz just surrounded
it's it's it was a scene kind of
reminiscent of what you see this a you
know we've seen this before it was it
last year there was a KKK rally back in
last July I believe and about 50 stupid
Klansmen came and there were a thousand
counter protesters there to answer them
a thousand 450 guys
thereby giving the 50 guys an incredible
amount of attention which is exactly
what they want so you've given them
exactly what they want
what they would not want is for the 50
for them to all come and then nobody to
react at all that would make them feel
very bad and very stupid and they are
very bad and stupid so they should feel
that way but when you all come out the
message you're sending them is wow we're
important what we're saying something
important we have to keep on saying I
think by the way here at the top it
could be it could be useful to contrast
this scene with something else think
about this protest and the coverage that
it gets in the attention etiquettes and
contrast that with another protest that
happens every year in DC and that for
that I refer to the March for Life the
March for Life you have up to sometimes
more than half a million people
pro-lifers who descend on DC to protest
abortion and when I say descend that
makes it's not really descend they come
in a very orderly fashion
and they're there and it's very peaceful
in there protesting abortion yet those
half a million people will not get even
close to half the amount of attention as
a handful of white nationalists can
attract the media somehow it's very
interesting you know it's it's it's it's
seems like a strange coincidence that
every year when the half a million
people are marching down the street the
media just has so many other things to
focus on they don't even they don't even
notice the half a million people walking
down through their own backyard
yet any time 30 80 30 white supremacists
get together they can attract the
undivided attention of the media
why is that
what's happening here how do you explain
this why is the media and why is the
left giving so much attention to these
fringe whack jobs and it's probably
overstating their relevance when I say
fringe it's more like these are fringe
of the fringe of the fringe yet they are
treated like powerful voices in the
national dialogue it's the media at the
left that treats them like they have
something important to say it has to
really be engaged with why is that I
mean you wouldn't if if you were walking
down the street and there was some crazy
guy standing on the street corner
shouting that he's the Queen of England
would you would you gather a hundred
people together to shouting you're not
the Queen of England
no would you get signs and hold them and
surround this one guy and then bring out
news cameras breaking news this man
claims he's the Queen of England
no you wouldn't do that because he's
just one irrelevant guy who cares what
he's saying just one crazy guy will take
that one crazy guy and then add a few
more of him and that's basically what we
have yet it gets this response why well
I think the answer is pretty obvious but
we'll talk about it anyway because
apparently it isn't obvious to everyone
I think they're there there are two
facets to this the two aspects to this
answer number one for the media and for
the left these these fringe of the
fringe of the fringe characters are
living breathing straw men and the fact
that they remember this march was called
unite the right can't even call it I
can't even call it March because there
were just a few guys while I it was more
just a stroll down the street it was a
walk down the street and a few guys that
were in this that were taking the stroll
down the street they were calling it
unites the right marching under the
auspices of uniting the right which just
makes it all the better for the left and
so the tactic for them is very
straightforward to treat the white
supremacist as if they are
representative of a large portion of the
right
you whip up hysteria and fear so that
the average unthinking person believes
that white supremacy is the animating
force of the right and thus the right is
itself a danger and a threat that's the
idea
pretty pretty easy plant pretty tactic
that's pretty easy to see it's the
opposite of what they do with the March
for Life
now with the March for Life and with
pro-lifers in general they want to give
the impression that the pro-life
movement is fringe and obscure and and
irrelevant
and they also want to say if they have
they have constructed a caricature of
pro-lifers that if you've ever spent any
time around pro-lifers at all if you've
ever been to the March for Life a really
any pro-life event you know how
ridiculous this caricature is but the
character that they've that they've come
up with that they've painted is that
pro-lifers are our old white men who get
together and shout and Ed women and
scream at women that's what that's the
that's the idea that that's the idea
that they want you to have in your head
of the pro-life movement but you'll
notice something
they whereas anytime a few white
nationalists get together the media is
there with cameras because they want to
get these people on camera yet with
pro-lifers while they tell us that pro
lifers are these hateful people to
scream and shout and you know our anti
woman for some reason any time pro
lifers actually get together the media
doesn't show up with cameras you think
they'd be eager to show up with cameras
to get this on camera and to show
everybody this is what pro lifers do yet
they're not there and you would think if
you've got five hundred thousand of
these people all together in DC five
hundred thousand old white men getting
together to scream at women
I mean you think the media would love to
have the cameras there to get down okay
and it's not just a march for life there
there are pro-life demonstrations in
this country every week hundreds of them
many abortion clinics have have a team
of pro lifers that are always there
outside
and what we're told is that they're out
there screaming at women and they're big
and they're you know they're they're
harassing and doing all this yet what
yet we rarely get that on camera why is
that
well it the answer is pretty simple
because the media doesn't want you to
see what pro-lifers actually look like
and who they actually are and what their
tactics actually are and what their
message actually is they don't want you
to see anything so they don't want to
bring their cameras down to the March
for Life and reveal all of the young
people and all of the women and that by
the way constant have ever been in the
March flyff you know that constitutes
the majority of the crowd women and
young people that's most of them they
don't want you to see that I want you to
see young people that I want you to see
the women they don't want you to see all
the racial minorities they don't want
you to see that it's white black
Hispanic Asian everybody all together
it's like a it's a it's a rainbow of
diversity it's the diversity that the
left always says that it wants and in
the pro-life movement it has it that's
it's got all and and not just Christians
either but it's mostly Christians but
but you all different Creed's as well so
all races creeds young people old people
men women all together marching side by
side and no they're not shouting they're
not screaming they're not being vulgar
unlike an Tifa that's not what they're
doing they're they're marching side by
side and they're they're singing songs
and they're praying and they're they
have smiles on their faces it's peaceful
its joyful and the media doesn't want
you to see
now the white supremacist on the other
hand present a much more convenient
picture because with the white
supremacist they are aggrieved angry
white men and that's what the media
that's that's the picture that the media
and the left wants you to have in your
head is of angry aggrieved white men
it's unfortunate for the media though
that so few of those types of men will
actually show up for these events and
they're very disappointed by that
because they're doing everything they
can to advertise these events and to
drive people out to promote it that
really is the tactic and it is so
unbelievably despicable
all of the contempt that is heaped on
the media as an institution is 100%
warranted because exactly for reasons
like this
they are playing a dangerous dishonest
despicable game and they know it they
they are literally at any time there's
gonna be a white supremacist rout they
advertise it they want people to show up
they want you there they are trying to
legitimize white supremacist white
supremacy they're trying to make it into
a mainstream thing there they are trying
they're especially trying to reach out
to any of those angry aggrieved lost
confused white men who mutt who may find
this appealing they're trying to reach
those and in and connect them with white
supremacy and bring them out
they're trying to get the ranks of white
supremacy up
that's the that's the game they're
playing
and it is
like I said it is it is you can't you
it's impossible to overstate how
contemptible it is what they're doing
attempting to legitimize neo-nazism so
that they can then take it they want to
get everybody there they want to make it
into a thing because white supremacy is
is not really a thing in America there
are a few of them there's some of that
that is an ideology that exists and I
mean some people said but any ideology
exhibit there's there are many horrible
things that people believe but it's not
really a thing in American culture I
have never met a white supremacist I
never have in my life I've never met a
single one in my life I never met a real
white supremacist and anytime you have a
rally where the meet and a media is
giving it all of their support
advertising promoting it yet they can
never get very many together so maybe
that's that's evidence that that it
really isn't a white supremacy isn't
really a driving force in America it's
not a relevant force it's not a relevant
thing it just isn't the media wants it
to be a thing so that they can then take
it and use it to discredit the right
and also in the meantime it's a great
story for them so it's ratings so for
them it's it's a win-win they get
ratings and they get to slander their
enemies and so that's what they want to
do and whatever chaos whatever violence
is caused in the meantime they're
perfectly fine with it they don't care
that's the first thing the second is so
that's the media that's why the media
does what it does with this stuff I
think for the counter protesters is also
another element to it for the counter
protesters there they are looking for a
cause they're looking for
something to do they're looking for
something to rally around it an easy
villain to to oppose that's what they're
looking for
I saw someone had on Twitter a picture
of one of the signs that somebody was
carrying at the counter protest and it
was a woman carrying a sign that said my
great-grandfather fought the Nazis and
now I'm doing the same it runs in the
family
listen your great-grandfather stormed
the beaches under a hail of bullets
and he fought the Nazis who at the time
were a powerful force in the world
trying to literally take over the globe
and he put his life on the line and and
and charged in there to actually defeat
the Nazis you on the other hand are
showing up with a thousand of your
friends to carry assigns to carry signs
and shout at 25 idiots walking down the
street that's what you're doing your
along with a thousand other people you
are surrounding twenty idiots walking
down the street and you're shouting at
them that's what you're doing it's not
the same there there is no comparison
whatsoever but the fact that there are
even a few Nazis in America presents for
people who are lost and have no cause
have no purpose in the life it presents
it presents a really convenient and easy
cause they say Oh Nazis yes well thing
everyone hates Nazis so that's a that's
that's an easy thing for me to be
against
and it is it of course we should all be
against Nazism but Nazism isn't a thing
anymore it's not it's not there's no
risk of Nazis taking over the world
anymore that because he our
great-grandfather's and our grandfathers
date they did away with that they took
care of that
that's done now the fact that there that
the fact that there are 25 Nazis in
America is not that doesn't mean
anything doesn't matter
it means nothing but it's a cause and
ironically
it's kind of both sides the thousand
[ __ ] counter protesters and the 50
neo-nazis or less than that they both
are looking for the same thing they they
both want cause they both want an
identity they both want a purpose and
that's why they're both there and the
media they're looking for a narrative
and they're looking for a story so
you've got this kind of unholy trinity
and this this mutual mutually beneficial
relationship between all these parties
where the counter protesters and the
neo-nazis they're looking for a Cause
looking for identity they're also
looking for attention they both want
attention the media they can give
attention but they're looking for a
narrative which is what which is what
the other side prefers I hope provides
to them
and that's how you end up with the
situation that we saw on Sunday
Bera Singh it's ridiculous and
[Music]
on the part of the media it really is as
I said contemptible
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed